Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live at the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, although you well
know me across the internet as Rawkode.
And I realized that I said Rawkode three
times in like five seconds.
However,
today we have an awesome episode as we're
going to take a look at the k0s
project, a Kubernetes distribution for all use cases.
Before we dive into that, there's just a
little bit of housekeeping. Please subscribe to the
YouTube channel and the button's right below my
face right now. So click that and tick
the bell. It means you're gonna get notifications
for all new episodes of Rawkode Live. I'm
gonna do my best to explore the vast
cloud native landscape and produce more videos and
more materials so that we can all learn
this crazy mess that we are in together.
If you wanna come and chat Cloud Native
and Kubernetes
and pretty much everything in between, there is
a Discord server available at Rawkode.chat.
Come and say hello, and I look forward
to meeting you.
We've also been kicking off the Rawkode Academy
courses this month, taking a look at a
complete guide to InfluxDB.
So take a look at the membership options.
You can support this channel for 99¢ per
month or become an incubating member, join the
courses, and there's more guest lectures and other
cool stuff coming very, very soon.
Alright. Back on track for today's session. We're
taking a look at k0s, and I'm joined
by Youssef from the Marantis team who works
on k0s. Hi there, Youssef. How are you?
Hey.
I'm I'm I'm I'm excited to join the
join the show and and and
and yeah. No. It's a pleasure to see
how it goes. Pleasure to have you here.
We're really looking forward to today's
today's session. I think there's a lot of
interest in
and k0s and people wanna see more, so
I'm sure we can give some lots more
details and explore it in our hands on
way that we do in this show.
Before
we dive into that, could you do us
a favor and just introduce yourself and tell
us a little bit about you? Alright. Alright.
So so, yeah, I'm I'm I'm I'm usually
and and and been working with containers and
and
Kubernetes
for,
well,
quite a quite a few years.
A bit bit of a historical kind of
background.
We we actually in in one of the
previous companies I worked for, we we actually
went to production with Docker
zero dot six
version.
And and and if I would would would
really have a time machine, I would go
back to that day and tell tell myself
that, oh, please please don't do it.
We
but but but I I I'm I'm in
general, I'm I'm kind of a stubborn person,
so I'm I'm still working with containers and
and and Kubernetes and whatnot. So so so
I'm I'm definitely definitely enjoying the whole cloud
native landscape and and and the the the
kind of all the all the possibilities that
it it provides and and,
well, of course, all the trouble that it
also gives us some days. So so
Yeah. To be in the container ecosystem that
early and still be in it today, you
must have the patience of a saint, you
see?
No. I don't. I don't. I'm as I
said, I'm stubborn. I'm just stubborn.
So so I I I still I still
enjoy working on on projects like like k
zero, for example, which which
kind of makes the technologies more accessible and
more easier to use. Because as we all
know, Kubernetes and and and basically all of
the all of the building blocks that we
have in the cloud native native landscape, they
are not the
are not the ones that are trivial to
grasp grasp. So
Alright.
Well, we already have our our first question
on the chat, which I think we'll get
to later. But we do see a quote,
Jen, and we'll do our best to answer
that at some point here.
To kick things off, you're gonna get us
through a little bit of slides, tell us
little bit about k0s, and then we're gonna
get hands on. So I am gonna Right.
Throw your slides up. They're now live. Take
it away, guys. Alright. Alright.
So just
I mean I mean, that's the that's the
whole point of this this Rawkode
streams is is to go hands on. So
so I'll I'll I'll glance just go through
this couple of slides quickly.
Where the where where the name comes is
is is basically
a sort of a play from the from
the, like, zero friction, zero dependencies.
And, of course, as as in any open
source, it's a zero cost. Well,
that's a that's another discussion whether whether whether
open source is really a fully zero cost,
but but but anyway,
we we try to make k0s
really the the like, the one of the
easiest easiest options to to boot up a
Kubernetes cluster.
So you don't really have to have to
be a, like, a, a seasoned expert and
and veteran in the industry to to to
really get get a, like, a production grade
cluster up and running.
And, also, the the one of the main
main drivers for everything that we do is
this zero dependencies.
So so we we try to make everything
everything in a in a stand alone way.
So so you only really need the k
zero's binary, and and and that includes everything
that that that you need to have in
order to run Kubernetes successfully in in basically
any Linux node.
That's that's where the zero in the in
in the name really comes from.
Thanks.
Of course, that I mean, that that there's
there's quite a quite a few different cube
distros out there
already existing, of course,
and and and it's it's not the first
distro that I'm actually working working on
either. But but one
of the one of the main reasons why
we why we kind of started to work
on k0s,
like, about a about a year ago,
What was really that basically,
there wasn't a distro that could allow allow
us to have, like, a super, super versatile
distro
that would fit the the from the, let's
say, from the basic cloud use case where
you have, like, VMs in a cloud and
and and and whatnot,
and all the way to the to the
environments where you have, like, industrial PCs and
and and lot of network segmentation
on the on on, let's say, like, a
like, on a factory floor, for example.
And and and that basically
took us took us to this this, like,
one of the main distinguishing features of k0s
is this full control plane isolation.
What it means is is is really that
the the control nodes
by default are not really part of the
cluster
from the networking point of view, from the
port scheduling point of view. So you we
we we don't really have, like, or any
any container d or or anything running on
the controller nodes so that it's it's, like,
fully impossible to schedule workloads either on purpose
or by accident to the to the control
nodes.
Always independence.
So so we
don't
or or we didn't really wanna wanna get
into into the into the
working mode where you where you have to
maintain, like, a lot of
and
deal with the dependencies between packages because
we we've done that actually in the past,
and and it was a
it was a sort of a nightmare to
to manage.
I mean I mean, it's it's it's
it's something that we we definitely wanted to
avoid and and and really get into this
one binary approach,
which is not like like a new thing.
K k three s has been has been
doing that already before, but we actually technically
do that slightly differently than than k three
s does.
And then, of course, we we we wanted
to have a, like, a pure upstream distro.
What I mean by that is that that
we don't maintain a fork of Kubernetes.
We don't we just basically take the the
upstream stuff and and just compile it as
as static binaries, and that's it. So so
you what what you get is is, like,
pure vanilla upstream Kubernetes.
Yeah. Batteries included.
What do we mean by batteries included is
that that we we we we have everything
that you need to have in a in
a Kubernetes cluster so that it it actually
works. So we bundle, like, container d for
the runtime. We bundle qProductor or Calico as
the CNI.
There, of course, etcd
for for data plane for the for the
data store as the as the state for
the control plane.
We've also added up that this client
from the from the k three s side.
So you can actually use SQLite or or
even MySQL as the as the data store.
But everything everything can be actually swapped to
your favorite solution if you if you really
need. So you can you can bring your
own container runtime if you if you have
a a good reason for use, like like
Docker,
for example. You can you can still use
that and and or
or or something else.
Then, of course, you can you can also
bring your own, like like, CNI implementation for,
for example, if you need to use or
want to use Weave or or something else
or Selium or something.
One of the one of the sort of
design
kind of drivers that we have is that
we we wanna we wanna keep the core
k zeros as a as a sort of
a bare bones. Like like,
I I think one way to one way
to describe it is to to to keep
it as as sort of a un opinionated.
So so that's one of the reasons why
we don't, like, bundle a lot of different
things. Like, we don't bundle, like, like, ingress
these service meshes or or anything into the
into the core k zeros
because
they they those those though you know, on
on that level, you have, like like, way
too many opinions.
So we are not really in the position
that that we can we can make a
selection for the for the majority of the
users that, okay, everybody should use this ingress.
We, of course, do have ways how to
how to sort of extend the the the
the core k zeros, and and and we've
built in mechanisms
that you can bay basically dump dump set
of
YAML on the on a certain place on
the on the disk on a controller node,
and and it'll be applied automatically.
Or or you you can you can actually
deploy Helm charts
via the the k0s configuration directly. So that's
sort of a reconciler for that also available.
So
but, of course,
in the end, it's just
Kubernetes.
So so you can, of course, extend it
in in in in many, different ways.
So I I already mentioned that that we
we we have this k0s as a single
binary. So so it's one way to look
at it is is actually that it's it's
sort of a self extracting binary.
So so
it's actually compiled
or or built in a way that that
we, of course, have the the k0s binary
itself, which has the the all the logic
of of setting up different components and running
those and configuring everything on the on the
Kubernetes side.
But do the basically basically, we append
differ other other binaries at the end of
the the the k zero's binary file.
And then at compile time, we actually calculate
the offset of different files. And and and
when we run k zero's, we actually extract
the binaries out at at at runtime on
the fly, and and and then we can
boot up to API container d and and
all the other needed processes as as separate
binaries.
So this is this is something that that
that we implemented in a in a quite
different way than compared, for example, to k
k three s. So so on k three
s, they they they basically compile everything into
a single binary and then just run different
things like you'd be APIs and others as
as basically as go routines on the on
the runtime.
In our case, the the cube API and
everything else, they are, like, real separate processes
on the on the host.
Can I ask a question?
Of course. Does that mean that k0s is,
like,
really just a supervisor for these other processes?
Yes. Yes. Yes. It's a it's a it's
a glorified process supervisor.
Yes. I like that approach. Very cool. Yep.
Yep.
About the control plane isolation, the the because
that's that that's something that that
that really is is a different thing compared
to
all the all the other distros that I
know of, at least.
Somebody might correct me if I'm wrong if
if there's some some other distro that implements
a similar thing.
So so as I as I mentioned, the
the cubelet, for example, is is is not
running on the controller nodes.
So we don't really need any need to
play with the the and tolerations and whatnot
to to to kind of isolate the control
plane nodes from the from the cluster.
And and and that
is that is something something if you if
you consider, like, your your typical
typical cluster setup with, for example, with q
KubeDM,
you get this
master node, which has these taints,
and and then you have to play with
lot of lot of tolerations and and and
whatnot with the with the workloads where you
when you're scheduling and and where you're scheduling
things at.
So so
we we wanted to get get sort of
away from that that
that paradigm.
And and and there's no, like, like, standard
or back
controls that would allow to say that, okay.
You see it's it's stupid enough that we
don't allow him to to to deploy anything
on the controller notes, for example.
You don't really have that those sort of
a standard controls for that in in Kubernetes.
Of course, you could do your own admission
controllers or or OPA policies or whatnot, but
but we
we wanted to wanted to really have a,
like, a full isolation with things things like,
say, scheduling to a control node is just
not technically possible.
It sort of simplifies things quite a bit.
What it actually allows us to do is
is also have a lot of versatility on
the deployment architectures.
So
we we we use this this connectivity
component
to to actually enable the communication between the
controllers and the worker nodes.
So,
basically,
the connectivity agent running on an on an
each worker node opens up a tunnel
to the
control nodes.
And then the control node, whenever like like,
whenever the API
API server needs to call the cube, let
to to exec into a port, like, the
logs of a port or or
port forwards and and whatnot.
The connection actually goes to through this tunnel.
So so you can think of it as
as as sort of a, like like, reverse
SSH tunnel in a way.
So what this really allows us to do
is is is
deployment architectures where your controllers can be actually
running on a, say, public cloud
and your workers running on your private data
center with no direct access from the Internet
at all.
I actually have a setup on my desk
here where I have couple of industrial PCs
running worker nodes, the controller for those is
actually on a cloud.
And my home connection definitely is not connected
to the or, I mean, it's connected to
Internet, of course, yeah, but but not from
the Internet. I don't I don't have any
port forwards or anything. So so it's a
it's a sort of a neat
neat way of enabling this needed communication and
still having, like, a lot of versatility on
this network segmentation and and whatnot.
Nice.
Alright. I think that's about it as a
as a slide intros. We can, of course,
talk about a lot of these these points
while we go through the hands on parts.
Yeah. Great. Thank you for that. That answered
a lot of the the questions that I
kinda had in my head coming into this.
The firewall one and the way the communication
works is fantastic. That was always one of
my favorite things about SaltStack is the fact
that, you know, the control plane or the
SaltStack master as they call it, the workers
only had to be able to open a
connection to that. And then they use the
zero m q messaging all the for all
the stuff back and forward. So it was
always the minions
or the worker that was in control of
the communication. It just makes the firewall rules
so simple because they just have to be
able to speak to this one thing over
here, and then you don't have to worry
about anything else because of the the tunnel
approach. Very nice. Exactly. Exactly.
And there's the the the surprisingly
surprisingly many features on the on the for
example, that are really tested on the on
the
conformance program even that really
must
where the where the API server must really
be able to open connections to the to
the kubelet, for example.
Okay. So we got
a question
in the chat, and it's from Ty.
We have a small follow-up from Daniel. So
Ty is just asking if we can talk
about maybe a comparison with k three's mini
cube, and Daniel has added on micro kits.
And I think we've kinda covered that. It
was already your slides, but is there anything
you wanted to add to that just to
kinda
add a bit more extra flavor?
Yeah. Well well, I I think as as
as we've kind of learned from the from
the get go is that that the the
most comparisons that we get is is with
k three s. And and I I think
partially we we throw ourselves with the naming
into the into the discussion, discussion, but but
that's a that's another discussion.
So so
I I think the main main technical difference
is the is is the fact that we
have this true control plane isolation
from the from the day one, and and
and it's sort of a not really hard
coded. You of course, nothing prevents you to
run the worker parts also on the same
nodes. Yeah. But then you have to take
care of the the taints and tolerations again.
So it's it's not really the, like, the
default way of of of deploying k0s.
Maybe maybe
one other other kind of real different differentiator
is is how we run these cube APIs
and container DS and whatnot. So so so
in case errors, they are really running as
as separate processes.
So it's not like everything is embedded into
a a single process.
Of course, there's like like with any solution,
there are pros and cons of of each
of these. So so
but in in
at least in in
in how we've been working with k0s
now for the for the year or past
year or so,
I think it is this actually having having,
like, this vanilla upstream Kubernetes
binaries.
It actually makes us makes us able to
really move fast. So so say that there's,
like, like, a new patch release of Kubernetes.
It's basically ours that we can ship new
k0s version because we don't have to deal
with the call module dependencies
and and and whatnot because
that that's always a nightmare when with Kubernetes.
Definitely.
Okay.
We're gonna get hands on in just a
minute. There's
one more question in the chat. I'll throw
up from Russell,
who is asking, can you balance the control
plane across local and cloud servers?
I'm assuming if you wanted a highly available
control plane, can you distribute them?
Yes. Yes. You can. You can.
But, of course, if you if you have
multiple controllers, you have to have, like, some
sort of a load balancer that that balances
the load between those those servers. Yeah. And
be careful of cloud providers ingress and egress
costs, Russell.
Very good.
Yeah.
Alright. Let me get my screen shared.
Keep the questions coming. We'll do our best
to answer them as we go. We're gonna
install
k zeros now on a couple of machines.
But I've got the homepage available.
I have the documentation.
I have my
Equinix metal servers. So I've got four. I
don't know what we're gonna do with them.
I assume one will do a maybe a
manual installation, and then we'll look at other
options for the other three.
Yep. Sounds good. Okay. So
we'll choose the
the getting started guide here. So
it seems to be the popular pattern these
days, but curl bash is the
installation method of choice. Is that what, like
I guess that's that's there is a convenience
for people that want to experiment. Cut the
tires, have a play with this. Yes.
Absolute
I mean, of course, nobody should
curl pipe bash
in production or any any, like, real environments.
So
so yeah. But but but but it's it's,
of course, it's it's, of course, convenient to
to to have these sort of face scripts
for for purposes like like today, for example.
Yeah. Definitely.
So this is
a bit to 20 o four machine.
I don't need to do anything. I can
just literally run this and it's gonna work.
And you mentioned on your slides that it
it's OS agnostic.
Yep. It can really just run anywhere. I
guess that's the beauty of just it being
aesthetically compelled by anywhere. Like, it'll Yep.
It'll run almost anywhere. Do you see people
using k0s
for
like I mean, this is a sizable machine.
You know? But I guess it runs on
IoT and
single board, Raspberry Pis, all that kind of
stuff as well?
But at at at least the worker part.
Yeah. Yeah. Because, I mean, in in the
end, we we we we have to remember
that the the control plan is is running
stuff like Kubernetes API at CD, which are,
as we know, quite resource hungry.
So
so
they they do take, like, at least a
gigabyte of RAM to to to be able
to really run the control plane. But the
the the the worker plane is actually actually
quite quite slim in a in a way
that
that that on on worker plan, the k0s
process itself, it's it's not really doing much
more than than being the glorified process supervisor.
So
I I I think it's nowadays
roughly 200 megs of RAM that it uses.
Right. Okay.
Yeah. Can get on board with that.
How big is the binary?
About
200 megs. Yeah. 70. One 70 five, it
seems. Yeah.
Alright.
Nice. That's just because we embed everything into
the same binary.
So Yeah. So this is
your k0s
extractor and supervisor.
You've got container d. You've got the cube
API server, and I guess in the cube
scheduler, the cube controller manager.
You got all of these things stuffed into
there. But I I I really do like
the supervisor approach rather than the the go
routine approach. I think that's that's pretty nice.
Yep. Yep.
Okay. So we can use the k zero's
binary. So it's obviously got some helper sub
commands here.
Yep. And this allows me to install k
zero's as a service on my machine. Okay.
Yep.
Let's just see what
let's see what we've got.
There's there's quite a few quite a few
different commands
and and and help our functionalities on the
on the binary too. So
Yeah. I can see
we've got an area gap set up. We've
got the controller APIs.
Oh, we've got backup stuff. What does that
do?
It takes a it it it basically takes
a snapshot on the on the on the
state of the control plane.
Nice. And spits out a terrible file.
And we got yeah. We got CTR, etcd,
install,
keep control,
start state. Sorry. Yeah. There's there's a fair
bit on there.
Let's run the so this is going to
install the controller. Is that just does that
mean control plan?
Yeah. Yeah. But if you if you add
that dash dash single option,
then it'll it'll basically
be a a sort of a special configuration
where where the controller is actually also spinning
up the worker parts because, well, it's a
it's a single node setup.
So it's a single node cluster.
So
it's it's it's mainly intended for this sort
of a developer use cases where you where
you just wanna run a a quick single
node setup for to test something, test your
application,
and and whatnot.
And then it also it it also actually
disabled disables
some of the some of the components which
we don't don't really need in this single
node use case.
K. Well,
that's
it? Alright. That's it.
And we have a start command. Right? Yeah.
K zero Yeah. Start. So that's just gonna
run all of my components for me.
Yep. And
It'll actually just call
basically, the the the system CTL to start
the k zero service.
Alright.
Okay. Let let let's talk about that, but
I'm really curious to see if this getting
all this is gonna work.
It did, right? Yeah. Is that okay? So
I'm curious now.
When I do the k0s
install controller,
it's creating system d services for each of
the components.
So No. K no. It's not. Okay. It
it create it creates a single
system d service for k zeros.
Alright. Okay.
And the and and and and the process
that that system d service
manages
is then the clarified process manager for the
other needed
Kubernetes components like API controller manager and whatnot.
Oh, yes. So here's our process tree here.
Yep.
Alright. So we've got our k0s, which is
running cane
with SQL lite. We got the API server,
the schedule, the controller manager, container d, the
kiblet, the proxy, the okay. Cool.
Okay. I understand that. Yeah. Perfect.
Yeah. That's that's neat. I like that.
Yep. So so so, basically, the install command
and start command are just like helper utility
functions to get get get your get your
system d setup easier
rather than having to write system d units
yourself because that's painful.
Alright.
My next question was why did get node
return nothing earlier, but it's returning something nice.
I guess we were a bit too early
in the API server and kubelet spinning up
for that to respond. But Yeah. Yeah. And
and and also as as as I mentioned
on the slides, the the it kind of
works as a as a self exacting binary.
So when when it boots up first time,
it it actually sees that, okay. I I
haven't extracted the binaries yet, so it'll take
a
bit of bit of this guy or two
to in the in the first boot.
Okay. Got it. Awesome.
Well, we now have a k0s cluster.
We've got access to a status command. Let's
see what that does.
Okay. Because of the version process ID,
parent
and the other thing.
Okay. Nice.
And I've already kind of done that.
I'm not gonna uninstall it because I just
Well, that's nice. Okay. So
pretty painless. I guess that's the developer experience
you're going for. Right? You just you just
want it to be get out the way
and just work. Yep.
That's the that's the zero friction that we
aim for.
And this is a completely
I mean, it's it's not that it's compliant.
I mean, it is upstream Kubernetes is what
you were seeing as well. Yep. It is.
It's not passing any I mean, it can
go past the compliance test, but it really
is upstream Kubernetes, which I think is pretty
quick. We actually we we actually do run
the the compliance test for for basically every
single release that we do,
which is, well, sort of my one of
my favorite things to nag about is the
the flakiness of the of the conformance. So
it's it's
sometimes it's annoying to get it passed, but
but we we do run it for every
single release that we do. I think just
saying sometimes that it's annoying to sums up
Kubernetes in general for me, to be fair.
True. True. So is there a 01/22 release
of k0s?
It's in the it's in the works. So,
hopefully hopefully, within next few weeks, we'll we'll
ship it out. And what's involved in that
process for you then on on that side?
Like, what are you looking for? What are
you testing before you adopt a new upstream
version?
We do we we do, of course, the
the full conformance testing, of of course, and
and we we also
also do
bit of stability testing and and and make
sure that everything works together nicely.
I mean, technically technically, if we if we
think about from the from the, like like,
k0s developer point of view from basically somebody
from from my team that that does the
actual
actual Kubernetes version change. He's actually changing the
version number in couple of files, and that's
technically it. But then, of course, we have
to make sure that everything still works. And
and especially now in the in the in
the 01/22 because there's there's actually stuff that
that fine that is finally being removed. So
we have to make sure that everything everything
works clean and still and and and
but, hopefully, in the next couple of weeks,
we we we will be able to do
the release. And we, of course, want always
wanna bundle in some bug fixes for k
zeros itself and and maybe maybe some cool
new features and and whatnot. So Cool.
Do I get to select the version of
k zeros when I install it? Or is
there way can I, like
what I'm curious, I'll ask the real question?
It's like, could we maybe run one twenty
one dot two or one twenty dot zero
and like do an upgrade of a cluster?
The first question we got at the start
from coach in there
is they were just curious and interesting how
they manage cluster upgrades, especially in production, if
we could talk about that. So is that
something you think we could run through?
Sure.
Sure. I mean,
technically
technically,
as upgrading
upgrading is is is is like just
get a new version of k0s binary itself
and and and restart the system d unit,
and that's it.
But, of course, when we are talking about
production services,
you have to do it in a, like,
controlled way.
And I think that's where that's where this
this k zero CTL
helper tool comes actually in a in a
in a in the play.
So so k zero CTL can actually do
it like a rolling manner. So it first
goes through the controllers one by one and
and and always waits that that the previous
one comes back online and and whatnot. And
then it'll it'll move into the into the
worker nodes and and do the normal, like,
upgrade
upgrade drain,
on sort
of a dance, what we call it.
Okay. Maybe that links us into another question
from Ty then. Ty is asking if there
is something similar to k c up or
ketchup, I think it's supposed to be pronounced.
Or is this where Feros comes in? Is
k zero CTL like ketchup? Or is I'm
not sure what Feras says. So Yeah. It
is it is k k zero CTL is
is is quite similar than than k three
as up ketchup.
There's too many numbers and and acronyms.
To try to try to say k three
s and k zero s and and k
three s up in the same sentence, and
your
tongue is twisted.
Yeah. I think I'll have a strong drink
before I try that, I think. Yeah. What's
Pharos? Is that something I should be familiar
with? Is that something to more interest? Or
No. It's Pharos is actually actually something that
I was I was working in the in
the past with. So it was a it
was a
cube distro that we did in the in
the past with with another company.
Oh, okay. Okay. Got it. So so if
if ties is
resemblance between k0s and faros, it's it's mainly
because there are some some of the same
people are are behind both of these. So
but I think from from technical point of
view, faros and and k zeros are actually
completely different. So
Okay. Got it.
Nice.
Okay. So should we take a look at
k zero CTL or k zero's control or
k zero's cuddle, whatever your preference is?
We we don't have a preference. So so
I always always use the the CTL, like,
kubectl, and
I guess that's the the the one of
the most important battles in the in the
cloud native ecosystem, whether it's kubectl or kubectl
or It's just technology in general. We all
pronounce something different. I mean, I can't like,
sometimes I say SQL lite, sometimes I say
SQL lite, sometimes I say MySQL, sometimes
I've given up trying to find any sort
of rhyme or reason to this.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm I'm pretty much the
same so.
Okay. So we are going to install
the k0s control
and I know on purpose they're gonna say
it a different way every single time.
Is there a brew tap, or would you
suggest I just grab the release from the
GitHub?
I
don't
I don't think there is a brew tap.
So probably just,
like, either go get it or just download
it.
Okay. Darwin.
That's
empty.
K0s cuddle.
Here's the definition of cuddle.
All close in one's arms is a way
of showing love or affection.
Thanks, Google.
There
we go.
We don't have
k0s
cuddle installed on our machine. So do you
wanna give us the the high level overview?
What is this tool for, and when should
people reach for it? Yep. So so so
caterers
cuddle is is is basically designed as a
as a sort of a helper
tool
to to like like a special purpose helper
tool to set up k zeros over multiple
different hosts.
So
as as we saw when you when you
when you did that setup for a for
a single note, that's, I mean, it's it's
super easy.
But but imagine you have have, like, hundreds
of notes in your cluster or or
even more than it I'm I'm at at
least myself, I'm I'm gonna be bored after
the second one. So
and and when when people are bored, they
make mistakes. So so, of course
so it's it's mainly like an like an
automation tool in a in a sense that
that
just automates the setup over multiple hosts. And
then as as already mentioned, it provides, like,
also the sort of a day two operational
benefits,
like like the the seamless upgrades of the
cluster and and and whatnot.
Okay. Perfect.
We've got a question from Alex in the
chat
who is wondering if there is a reason
for the change in the default CNI from
Calico to KubeRotor.
Right.
The main reasoning actually was the the resource
usage.
So
lot of the lot of the use cases
we we saw early on where k0s is
being used is is
is use cases where where the infrastructure
is is
or or has less resources.
Like, these industrial PCs and and sort of,
like, edge computing
use cases, whatever edge means for people. But
but but
but those sort of use cases where where
you you really have want to want to
save, like, like, lot of lot of the
resources or as much as resources as possible.
So that was one of the one of
the main drivers.
And and, actually, at sort of adjacent to
that is is the fact that Calico
at that time I I haven't actually checked
the the latest versions, but but at that
time, it didn't actually support 32 bit ARM
at all,
which gProuder does so. So those were the
main main two drivers.
Perfect.
Okay. So let's jump back over to the
documentation.
We have the tool,
and we can use an edit command to
generate, I guess, just a default configuration.
Yep.
Okay. So this is
a
Is it an actual
CRD or just made to look like one?
Like, can I apply this to a Kubernetes
cluster with some definitions of No? Can't. Not
yet? At
least at at least currently, you can't. But
it's it's it's definitely something something that we
had in mind that that that that from
the day one, let's make this look like
a Kubernetes resource. So if we ever want
to do that, then we can.
A cross plane provider that could use this
resource would be really sweet and just have
it go out and do all my upgrades
and and stuff. Yep.
Okay.
So
this just expects
me to have some hosts, which fortunately I
have got a
user, a key path.
Yep. And then I tell the version of
k zero's that I want. So this is
really a kind of an orchestration tool. I'm
gonna I'm assuming I'm gonna do some sort
of k zero CTL
apply or converge or whatever the sub command
is. It's gonna read this file. It's gonna
SSH onto all of these machines and give
me back a multi node cluster.
Yes. Exactly. Exactly.
Alright. Okay. So let's drop in some IP
addresses here from my Equinix console.
So we've already burned machine one, so we
jump for two.
If I ignore the key path, will it
use my host default
agent?
Yes.
Good. Because I
Well, we're about to find out because I've
got a bit of a weird s s
h set up. So I may have to
Okay. Quickly jam some keys, but we'll work
at what happens.
And I need to copy these five lines
and one more IP address.
Okay. And we're gonna install 121 by three
and save.
Okay. Yep.
And apply. Awesome. Okay. Yep.
What do you think the chances of this
working with my SSH setup are? Are we
feeling confident?
I'm I'm feeling fairly confident. Yes. I
just remember that we've we've had some problems
with the with SSH agent based setups, but
but
I think it worked. My
ad blocker is clearly blocking the title metrics,
though. But other than that, I think we're
okay.
I think there's a there's a flag or
environment variable for you to actually just disable
the metric stuff completely.
Sorry. When I first brought in this ad
blocker to my home network, I actually blocked
the traffic for the stream software. So that
was the the fun couple of days for
me to try to debug that.
Guess it's just doing this thing. How long
does it take? I guess it's just going
on to each machine. Does it do them
concurrently?
Like, at the same time, is it spawned
on multiple processes or does it do the
control plane first and
It it it it does the the control
plane first, of course. I mean, there's no
point of of going to the work or
not if we don't get the control plane
working first. So
Yeah. Makes sense.
I guess Oh my god. It's it's annoying
to see these errors,
actually. I don't really, really, really wanna get
rid of that. I mean,
if if if sending the metrics actually errors
out to
you as a user shouldn't really care or
have to care about that fact. So
Yeah. I guess I need to do I
need to do something about that.
I I definitely am supportive, though of open
source software having this at home. It's one
of the most difficult things in the world
is trying to understand what versions of people
are using and and and they're still actively
using it because you need to know where
to apply
effort and maintenance and stuff like that. Yeah.
Exactly. It's just that projects are doing this
now. It's I think it's better longer term.
Yep. If I could enable it just for
this offer, I would. I promise.
So I
can run
what I see here is this is gonna
download that cube config to my local director.
Yep.
Or it it'll it'll actually
spit it out on the on the screen.
So you'll have to now probably pipe it
to something.
Yeah. We didn't get any error messages. That's
okay.
Wonder
if there is a flag.
Must be an environment variable. Okay.
So And it said that it it might
be like a like a hidden option.
Oh, I'm gonna need to
kubectl,
Look at that. Yep.
Everything's
up and running and fine and dandy.
But but here you actually see that that
because remember that you have three hosts in
the in the YAML.
The control plane is not listed. Right? Because
it's not running a kubelet or even container
d or else like that. Yep. Exactly. Exactly.
Yeah. When when I first seen two, was
like, oh, we're still waiting on one. And
I was like, oh, no. It's it's the
the control plane isolation.
Yep.
That that's probably the the the most asked
question that we see on Slack or or
even in in GitHub issues that that why
don't I see my
my note here?
You shouldn't.
So the the the it it basically works
exactly like like if you if you get
your Kubernetes cluster from Amazon, say,
you don't see the controller nodes. You just
get the API address, and that's it. It's
it's pretty similar here.
Nice.
Well, that's pretty neat. I like that tool,
and it's
pretty straightforward.
You know? Just adding
the IP addresses of each of my machines.
I like to just use the
the SSH agent. I was worried that wasn't
gonna work, but it just worked.
So, yeah, pretty solid tool. I like that
a lot.
Is there anything else with k zero CTL
we should take a look at?
I
think that that that covers the that covers
the the the, like, the sort of basic
basic stuff.
I'm gonna run a platform. Of course, now
you now you.
Yeah. Well,
it it should actually dump you a a
tarball in your
current
Yeah.
Directory.
Yep.
So what is that backup of? Is that
the database?
Yeah. It's the kind database,
the
the the CA certificates,
and and and,
basically, the
needed state of the control plane.
Okay. Awesome.
I mean, of course, the we we we
have to get that that CA into a
safe
backup place because if you if you wanna
change the CA on the cluster, then, well,
it's a
slightly more difficult exercise.
Yes. Definitely.
Let's tackle a couple of questions, and then
we'll see if there's anything else we wanna
just, we wanna run over. So we've got
one more from Alex. It's just a follow-up
from the Kaleckel cube rooter question.
And I guess Alex is just saying, yeah,
that makes sense. If we want to use
on local and for a medium sized virtual
machines, I can still use Calico. Right? So
I think what you said is it's all
swappable. Right? And all this yeah.
And and and it's it's, of course, all
swappable, but but we do include Calico
within k0s itself. So so k zeros itself
has the capability to run either or Calico.
But then, of course, there's a third option.
You're, like, bring your own. So so you
can deploy k zeros without any CNI, and
then it's up to you to configure whatever
CNI you you wanna use. But we we
support out of box,
Calico and Cube Router.
Alright. Thank you.
Is
asking,
so how do I debug the control plane?
I guess if something goes wrong, what what's
the options then? Is it SSH onto the
machine?
Usually.
Yeah. Usually. Yeah. Or
use use whatever
whatever mechanisms
that you that you use to to connect
the note to the notes and and and
whatnot. So
Yeah. So I guess as part of the
you know, when you're deploying k zero's control
plane node, you'll probably wanna stick some monitoring
on that machine, get some logs out of
it, and a few other bits and pieces.
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Okay.
Yeah. I don't think Alex has a question
there. I think Alex is just agreeing with
the control plane not showing up on the
list. So we're all good.
Alright. Awesome. Really cool project.
I like that YAML format and just spinning
up and deploying the machines. I think that
will save me a lot of time and
a lot of manual steps.
Is there Yep. Anything else with k0s or
a k0s CTL that you think we should
cover before we finish up today?
I was I was
not really planning, but I was I was
prepared to to show a demo with k
zero CTL where I actually integrated with Terraform
if if if that is something that that
people would be interested to see. I think
we would love to see that if you're
happy to share. Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Alright. Your screen is up. We can see
Versus Code and your terminal. Take a look.
Yep. Excellent.
Let me bump up the font a bit.
The font is good.
So,
basically, I'm I'm I'm using a a smaller
European cloud provider called Hetzner for this demo,
mainly because they are super, super fast to
spin up all the all the needed needed
infrastructure
for demo purposes.
So it's it's basically a simple simple,
like, three plus three case where I spin
up
three
controllers and and three workers and and with
the c x 31
type. So I think that, if I remember
correctly, that's like
four CPUs and four gigs of RAM.
So
but I mean, it's a it's a it's
a typical three plus three case.
And and as we as as we learned
from the slides and the discussion,
whenever I run
AJ control plane, of course, have to have
a load balancer in front. So so my
Terraform also deploys this
Hessner
load balancer thing and connects it to the
to the workers and the the usual cloud
cloud stuff.
Let's let's call it cloud stuff. People
get sometimes annoyed when I refer to com
complex technical things as stuff.
I'm okay with it. They're alright.
Yeah. Yeah.
One of the one of the
neat tricks that that we we have in
some of the examples and and and some
of the documentation on case or CTL is
this use of this Terraform output variables.
So,
basically, I have the the the hosts
like you had in the YAML.
I I I basically concatenate the list of
controllers and workers, and I just have the
similar structure or the same structure as you
had in in YAML in in Terraform output.
So
and then then I define that the output
is actually a YAML encoded value of this
Terraform variables.
So what what in the end I actually
get out is is pretty much the same
that, like like, you did manually.
So what this allows me to do is
is
is do stuff like like
Terraform apply.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I trust what I'm doing.
I don't really, but
let's assume that I do.
Yeah. You see see the main reason why
I use Hetzner in in many of the
demos because it takes, like, twenty seconds to
boot up six
six VMs and a and a load balancer
connected to those. So Yeah. That was fast.
Pretty neat.
Yeah.
So
what I'll do is I'll I'll take the
output as a raw
because that that'll be the YAML encoded value.
And then I I can actually pipe it
to k zero CTL.
Apply,
and then we don't need this redirection.
So, basically, I said said that, okay. Let's
apply whatever you get from the standard input.
So this is a sort of a neat
pattern that we can use with k zero
CTL tool.
So imagine you could actually actually have, like,
a, like, a
CI
CD
sort of a pipeline
for your infrastructure
and and for your Kubernetes clusters
with with this.
Yeah. I can see, like, a GitHub action
that runs a Terraform apply, and it passes
the
the output forward. And then you got the
k zero CTL kick in, and it off
it goes and does its thing. So Yep.
Exactly. Exactly. Or maybe in future, you could
actually actually dump the dump the k zero
CTL YAML in a in a Kubernetes API,
and then some some magic
some work kicks in then.
Yeah. I'm looking forward to seeing that crosswind
provider. You'll have that ready for me next
week. Right? I
no. No promises. No promises. No promises.
But to be honest, it's not the first
time I've I've heard the idea. So
Yeah. I think it would work really, really
well.
Because you could have like a k zeros
that runs cross plane on a single node
setup and then apply your other k zero's
control YAML's to it and then have the
controller cross plane or otherwise go and create
more virtual machines and deploy. That would be
a pretty nice setup. I like that. Yep.
Yep. Yep.
Or then what the what the
what the, like, the this true control plane
isolation actually actually allows us to do is
is you could basically run the k0s
controllers
in a pod
because there's no requirements for kubelet or anything
else.
So what's it's it's just set of normal
processes. So what's preventing
running in a in a pod.
Yeah. Definitely.
So there's sort of a miter ship type
of a type of a pattern.
Right. Looks like it's done.
Yep. It's done. I got my three plus
three setup done and and
yep. One sec. Let's dump it out.
Export.
Keep config.
Keep
k0s.
Get node
pod
dash a.
And there we go.
One thirty node k zero's cluster. Yep.
And then h a h a control plane
with load balancer and everything, and it took
me, like, few minutes.
Even with even with my typing speed. So
Very nice. I like that.
Yeah.
But I think that that that
of course, we or or it it doesn't,
of course, matter how how people set up
the k0s cluster whether you use, like like,
Chefs or Ansible or
Solstacks
or whatever tools you use. It doesn't really
matter. We just wanted to build this sort
of a,
special purpose tool
to help with the day two operations,
like upgrades and and everything. So, it'll it'll
make life easier
in in many cases.
Awesome.
Maybe we can actually actually
try an upgrade.
Where did I have the version? It's
variable.
Yes. And the the virus fail.
The virus file actually contains a
secret too, so I'll switch.
You don't see the screen now. Right? No.
But I think it did show us a
virus fail at the start.
I I saw showed the example for Ah,
the example. Right. Okay. Gotcha. Yeah.
Really should learn
to do these sort of things. That's alright.
I flash my secrets on the show a
couple of times a week. People have been
nice and and not hacked me yet. So
thanks, audience. Yeah.
Alright. So what I what I did actually
because we we see that we actually have
this 21 to two version running. So
so I'm gonna actually bump it up to
to 21 to three now.
So it's it's, I have to do that.
Apply for the Terraform first.
You see that in in the Terraform output
that the version actually changes.
Mhmm. Doesn't change anything else.
Then I'll do the
output and
apply
thing.
We'll see what the the upgrade process actually
looks like.
Let me
erase that a bit. Based on what you
said earlier, what k zero's control is gonna
do is SSH on to each machine, pull
the latest binary, and then basically just flip
them over?
Yep.
Okay.
We've
got a a question in the chat from.
How's
it going?
As a Windows workers know, it's something that
has been thought of or working on?
We do have a experimental support for Windows
workers too. So in the in the k
zero's download
release page, you actually see a k zero's
dot exit already existing. There you go.
Try it out, and then I'll let us
know how you get on.
Yeah.
It has an experimental label, so be very
Nuno is not shy from experimental labels. He
is always playing with That's what I've learned
too.
Yep. Yeah.
But I think that's the the the the
the whole, like, cloud native native world that
that
what I've been I've been basically telling everybody
whenever working with Kubernetes or or anything. If
you if you see, like like,
something dash something slash v one beta one,
well, just use it. It's stable enough. Yeah.
V one beta one's too mature for me.
If it's not an alpha API, I'm not
interested.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So beta bet beta is
the new stable in the Exactly. Cloud native
world. So
Well, it was only 01/01/2016
where we could write a v one beta
one for leak deployments and everything else. Like
yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. If it's v one, then it's
almost like legacy already.
Right.
Alright. So so what what what do you
see? What actually happened is that
it upgrades the controllers basically one by one,
and then it moves on to the onto
the workers.
But because I have, like, three workers only,
we can't really do that, like, in parallel
upgrades that well. So by default, the the
the k zero's cuddle actually takes,
like, 10%
of your notes and and runs the the
the upgrade in parallel
for that 10% at a time. So if
you have 20 notes, it'll actually update two
notes at a time and and and so
on.
So it and and then it actually does
this this typical upgrade
or the drain update on cord and dance
for each of the notes. And and at
at all steps, it waits that everything becomes
ready again and
whatnot.
Awesome.
Very cool.
I'm glad we stuck around for that extra
bit of demo. The upgrade was nice. I
mean, we got some love in the chat
for the upgrade as well. Very cool.
Alright.
Well, that is k0s
everyone. I hope you liked that. You've
got five seconds to get any more questions
into that chat before we say goodbye and
let you say get back to the day.
Well, if you have any questions, drop them
in there.
So I'll finish with a a question that
I ask quite often. It's just like,
is k0s
finished, complete? Are you just tracking upstream now,
or do you have any new shiny stuff
coming down the line?
We do have we do have some new
shiny stuff coming up. So one
of the one of the things that we
are we are working work actually quite early
early in the process, but but we've started
to work on a on a feature what
we call, like, autopilot.
What it'll it'll do is is is it'll
take the cluster itself,
and and
it'll it'll apply
the cluster itself will handle all the upgrades
and updates and everything by itself.
So we'll we'll basically basically bundle this upgrade
logic and all the control mechanisms
between the node trains and and and on
coordinates and whatnot. We'll we'll bake it into
the into the control plane itself.
So, basically, it's a it's a cluster that
is on an autopilot
in a way.
Nice. Sign me up for that.
We got one question that has snuck in
there. So is asking it. It's can the
10% be controlled? I assume this is in
relation to that upgrade. Yeah.
Oh,
I I
suppose that it is.
If it's not, then then we have to
make it as an argument or some sort
of a
parameter on somewhere.
Yeah. To request welcome. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
It's just changing one magic number to something
else.
Alright. There's maybe a a good idea for
a a nice simple contribution that cook gen.
So if it isn't configurable already,
feel free to give that a go.
Yep. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Alright. Well, thank you so much for joining
me today. Really good to see that. Our
demo well, I say our demo. Your demo
went off without a hitch. It was really
nice. I hadn't actually used Tertra cloud before,
but the speed of spinning that up was
pretty impressive. So maybe I need to check
that out at some point as well. Alex,
we can then move one final question.
We we can do it. Right? Yeah. We
got a little bit of time. Yeah.
Alex says, I tried once to deploy Portworx
to k0s, but I could not get it
to work. Any ideas if it has something
to do with the locations where it stores
the files or configurations?
I
I do remember reading about that issue,
but I I
can't remember the the details where we where
we landed on on.
And and to be honest, I don't I
don't really I don't really
know port works at all, how it works
and what it does. So so
but it it probably has something to do
with that where where where k0s
puts in in in the files and and
sockets and and everything. Everything. So that that's
why that's my best guess based on based
on the information that I I have and
and know about Portworx.
Alright. No worries.
Okay. We got a thank you from Ty
in the chat. So, yeah, we're gonna finish
this up. Thank you again. You see, really
good. Love the demos. Very cool. Any last
words before we before I let you go?
Well, as as as in any open source
project, just
we we always appreciate feedback and and and
both
bulk reports and and feature requests and and
everything in in in between and and even
better if if you can pull up a
PR.
But, yeah, thanks for thanks for having me
join the session, and I I I I
really enjoyed the the format
of of your sessions here. So Awesome. Hands
on and not not afraid of of, demo
effects.
No. No. I've I've I I look silly
enough on a stream regularly, so I'm not
fazed by it anymore. But Yeah. Thank you.
It was great fun, and I'll hopefully speak
to you again soon. Have a great day,
guys. Alright.
Bye.